You can reduce your risk for cancer by avoiding carcinogens. Here are some ways.
You will need, non - styrene food packaging and organic foods.
Step one: Avoid foam food packaging which contains styrene that can be transferred to food inside.
Animal studies have shown a link to cancer.
Styrene was found in the urine samples of 87% of people tested...
...in a Center for Disease Control and Prevention study.
Step two: Avoid taking your clothes to dry cleaners that use tetrachloroethylene as a cleaning compound.
The agent has been found to cause liver cancer and leukemia in rats.
Alternative dry cleaning compounds include silicon and hydrocarbon - based solvents.
Step three: Limit your exposure to titanium dioxide...
...which is found in cosmetics, paints, paper, and plastics.
Animal studies have confirmed the compound's carcinogenicity.
The jury is still out on whether titanium dioxide nanoparticles found in cosmetics...
... can be absorbed by the skin and if they are absorbed what their effects would be.
Step four: Avoid diesel exhaust.
These fumes have been linked to cancer in animal studies.
Since diesel fumes are practically everywhere,...
...your best bet for avoiding them is probably to move to an unpopulated tropical island.
Step five: Reduce your exposure to aromatic hydrocarbons by limiting...
...your consumption of smoked, barbecued, or burnt foods.
Step six: Consider eating more organic foods.
Organic foods contain lower concentrations of problematic food additives.
Now you can enjoy a long healthy life.
Did you know...
...approximately 100 new food and color additive petitions...
...are submitted to the US Food and Drug Administration annually.
Additives cannot be approved that they are found to cause cancer in humans or animals.